Trump's taking on Twitter the president
threatening to regulate or close down
social media companies after Twitter
started fact-checking his tweets Trump
accusing the platform of silencing
conservatives and trying to interfere
with the 2020 elections it's in response
to Twitter adding a warning label to his
tweets about mail-in ballots and voter
fraud so Greg this is a whole can of
worms but Twitter is using CNN and the
Washington Post as their fact checkers
well I mean think about this what's
easier to throw away a bag of votes or
get a Russian troll farm to help you
swing an election I think it's easier to
throw away a bag of votes but anyway the
thing is this whole fact-checking thing
is designed as a way as a way to tackle
misinformation which would be good if
there was a balance in misinformation
but we do know from research that the
news media is about 90% liberal so the
right generally is over policed daily
compared to the left they look at it's
like a highway where only the red cars
get pulled over while the blue cars keep
going that's how we police
misinformation and I think that this
kind of fact-checking thing this is an
example of it we'll just extend the
practice of going after things that are
said by Trump or said by conservative
outfits while all I mean imagine if you
tried to fact-checked everything said
against Trump from the Russian collusion
to the accusations of racism to the 25th
amendment that went on for a couple of
months and then now you have the blood
libel of the coronavirus in which you
have certain people on MSNBC saying you
know he's got a hundred thousand deaths
on his hands it's impossible to actually
fact check the immensity of these claims
against Trump so you know it's only
gonna work one way they're just gonna
pull over the red cars and let the blue
cars drive by you know Dana for a while
now big social media companies like
Twitter and Facebook have been
threatened with regulation because they
claim that they're just a public
platform but then they do things like
edit content ban and content in this
case fact-check president Trump's tweets
but you interviewed Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg for your show tomorrow
let's take us
peek at that and get your response
Twitter decided for the first time ever
to fact-check one of President Trump's
tweets I'm wondering if you thought that
the Twitter may have made the wrong
decision here we have a different policy
I think than Twitter on this you know I
just believed strongly that that
Facebook shouldn't be the arbiter of
truth of everything that people say
online I think in general private
companies probably shouldn't be
especially these platform companies
shouldn't be in the position of doing
that Dana so that is a policy that the
Facebook team put in place last October
around the time that I first interviewed
him and the uproar from the left has
never led up against Facebook on this
they want him to be policing president
Trump's tweets but not their own and it
has been something pretty interesting to
watch that they've stuck to their guns I
further asked him about like well what
would what would be the line you know is
there a line that they would cross and
he's very clear they look back at the
Supreme Court rulings from the past in
terms of free speech and if it doesn't
have imminent harm to somebody or
misinformation that would hurt somebody
then for when it comes to a political
speech they're gonna be hands-off and I
think that that's probably the right
decision like if I was sitting there I
think that I don't know exactly what I
would do I don't have all the
information but I think that's the right
thing and a free speech is something
that Americans cherish American
companies should cherish and there was
no need for Twitter to get involved
yesterday like why fact check that
particular tweak there are hundreds of
tweets that you could choose but they
chose the mail and voting and there is
controversy about mail-in voting there
are statistics there are different
things you know it took Seattle about 10
years to get it right Jason Rance wrote
a big a great piece on this to explain
that it's pretty good now but it took 10
years for them to get it to be good so I
think there's room for a debate I just
don't understand why Twitter decide to
step in it on that particular tweet
yesterday when there was plenty of other
tweets including one yesterday that they
could have taken action on well Jesse
shouldn't they be also than fact
checking I don't know members of the
Chinese Communist Party who were you
know spewing lies about the coronavirus
on Twitter they aren't doing that no
because they have too much money in
China I mean why don't they fact check
pencil-neck I mean he's been lying about
collusion for three years I'd put a
little fact-check behind any of those
tweets and I know why they chose this to
fact-check because it's the only way
they're gonna beat Trump is ballot
harvesting it's not even a fact check
Katie it's spin I mean like I have I
have sheets of paper here of reports
that I found on Twitter that say that
there's a lot of abuse with mail ballots
it's from the New York Times the apoE
CBS I mean these aren't fact checkers
this is like the Democrat state of the
union rebuttal and they don't understand
how weak it makes the left look because
cuz Biden can't take them out the media
can't take them out now they're asking
big tech for help I mean you guys can't
do this on your own why can't Biden
retweet Trump and say this or that
that's his job and then you find out the
guy in charge of enforcing the rules on
Twitter is some left-wing hack that
called the Trump folks Nazis the whole
things so cooked up that it's it's
almost helping the president because it
makes him again look like he's got
everybody against them you know Twitter
the FBI the mainstream media and he's
going to shove it right back in their
face in November so Donna is just part
of heroes Ronen all of the wine and all
of it is one and Jesus Christ Jesse I
mean I wish I could sing you some tissue
but I would have to be six feet from you
so therefore I would have to call the
point you're the one that's wasting the
social media complain the social media
social media buy the real content ease
around tremendously conspiracy silly
you're talking about me because you're
talking he's talking about me because
you're talking nonsense these conspiracy
theories do cost lies and the
misinformation that you put out the
president tweet should have been deleted
I would have deleted the president's
tweet and you know why because it's a
bald-faced lie it's Republicans who use
absentee ballots to get out their votes
that has traditionally been the way the
Republicans have always motivated their
voters go ahead and vote early so I
think that the social media platform
companies should regulate themselves and
they should make sure that these
conspiracy theories the one the
president put out about Joe Scarborough
it should be deleted the lies need to
stop there's no First Amendment right to
lie period you can't okay
and with that we will move actually you
can you can't right right to lie there's
no First Amendment right to live you
just go ahead and lie I can say I'm six
feet are you know but I would but I
would put alright well because I'm sure
whatever the politicians Don it if you
couldn't lie you'd have no politics
there's no first of your progress we